The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: But today, we'll
start with the customer
information one, which I
really will admit that probably
some of you folks know
more about this than I
do at this point.
But what I'm going
to do is cover
the trends that
have been happening
in the last couple of years.
And then I'd like to get into
a discussion, towards the end,
about where we should go.
Because where we're starting
to do some research on this.
Apar, who's usually
in the class, who's
doing some stuff here.
And we can talk a little
bit more about this.
This is the outline essentially
just saying where we've been
and where we're going and
some ideas, essentially--
both my personal
ones and others'.
This is actually a
lecture that started --
The first version of this
was done by Nigel Wilson.
So I gotta give him a
lot of credit for this.
And then we've evolved
it, as it went,
over the last several years.
So this is a spectrum of
components of customer
information-- or characteristics
of customer information,
really--
and how it's evolved from what
transit agencies are providing
to their customers.
On the left is what
was the old stuff.
On the right is
where it's going.
And it's not all there yet.
But generally, things have
been moving, and fairly quickly
in the last couple of
years, from an operator
view to a customer view.
Operators used to
just tell people
what their schedule was and
barely where the trains were.
There were some maps out there.
But way-finding
was very, very bad.
And so, essentially, you
have to pick up these pieces
of paper, which were static.
And now it's moving to a more
dynamic real time perspective.
Everything was always pre-trip
or pre-planning your trip.
And now, there's some
indication that things
are getting more en route.
You have these real time apps
that we'll talk a little bit
about.
The last two are the ones that
probably haven't moved quite as
fast as some would have hoped.
I think most of the
customer information
that's out there still treats
everyone as a generic customer.
It doesn't really see
your particular needs,
although there are things
like service alerts
that you sign up for
very specific routes
and things like that.
But there's not too
much specific to you.
And then, generally,
you've got to look still
for the information and
pull it up yourself.
It's not coming to you without
you taking any action, in most
of these apps, although
some of the apps
are starting to move that way.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: The active
systems and passive systems,
is that supposed to be
the other way around?
What's with the active part?
PROFESSOR: The active part
is from the perspective
of the customer.
The customer has to
actively seek out
the information as
opposed to it coming
to him without doing anything.
OK.
Yeah.
And anybody, you can
interrupt, as well.
I like the give and take.
It's the technologies that allow
these things to include things
that you've pretty much
talked about here, probably
already, automatic
vehicle location
systems, automatic
scheduling systems,
so that the whole data of the
mission of the transit agency
is now in digital form.
And more generally, is available
to the public through what
most [INAUDIBLE] used to call
the Google Transit Data Feed.
And now it's the General
Transit Data Feed.
Because, basically, everybody
adopted what Google started.
And it provides
universal formats
that all the transit
agencies have basically
converted their data to.
GPS and Wi-Fi cell phones.
GPS is used on the vehicles,
generally, sometimes
in the cell phones.
But essentially,
provides your location.
And this is where the
customer specific stuff
has gotten better.
Because that technology
has allowed it.
If you didn't have a
phone that told everybody
where you were you wouldn't
be able to get information
as good as you do now.
AFC provides a database
on your trip-making.
And that's important
for two reasons.
One, it allows the agency to
know where people are traveling
much better than they used to.
And it also allows
them, if they so desire,
to start to develop stuff for
you based on your history.
And this is a little
bit controversial.
We still have a
lot of discussions
with transit agencies about
the privacy of the data
and tracking you through
there and your taps.
But frankly, all the commercial
people were doing this.
And I think, the customers
come to expect it.
And the agencies have
to get over this hump,
do a privacy policy
that says, we're
going to use this
data in these ways.
And we're going to
give people information
based on their previous travel.
I don't think too many
people have done that yet,
but they're thinking about it.
And unfortunately, sometimes
the government lawyers
are more obstinate
about doing things
like this than the private
sector lawyers who generally--
my biased observation
is, the private lawyers
finds a way to do with
the company management
wants them to do.
The government
lawyers finds a way
to tell management
they can't do what
they want to do, in many cases.
And it's unfortunate
from that perspective.
And then, obviously, wireless
communications and the apps
that have been developed.
So before Google
Transit, and this
is probably ancient
in your eyes,
but there used to
be a bunch of--
not a bunch-- about
three or four or five--
software companies worldwide
who did these things.
And they were doing it
with really old technology.
And they were mainframe systems.
And they collected
literally, $1 million
for each Transit Authority.
And it was funny to see Google
do this for free, essentially.
Because these companies almost--
a lot of them just died
because of the competition.
So when they first did
this, we were all amazed.
Because a lot of the
big transit authorities
had invested lots
and lots of money
to the majority of planners.
And they involved a tremendous
amount of data preparation
and a lot of customization
for each city.
And this was a breakthrough
that nobody ever saw.
Nobody quite
understood why Google
was doing it at the time.
But it was welcomed.
And there's some funny stories
about how it was then adapted.
Because a lot of the big
transit authorities already
had these trip planners
that they invested
these millions of dollars on.
And they were loathe
to give them up.
And they were loathe to then
change the input to the Google
Trip input.
Because all the formats
of these other things
were all proprietary.
And they basically had
to do a lot of work
to get it into Google transit.
But they got embarrassed
into it by students, students
even on the high
school level, who
really took their
towns' schedules
and put them into
Google transit.
And this was done in
city after city, really.
In some cases, in big
cities, to show them up.
And other cases,
in little cities,
because they just didn't
have the staff to do it.
So it was a great development.
You've seen the apps that--
next vehicle arrival
times, but on your phone,
which you all probably use.
There's many new apps.
Some of them are good.
Some of them aren't so good.
Give the Google data out.
And have other people
write the apps.
That was the chosen
path, because they
realize they couldn't do it as
quickly as private people could
do it.
And they, essentially,
let this go.
My criticism of this approach--
I think in Boston we had
between 35 and 45 transit
apps, none of which
were well supported
for about two or three years.
Nobody quite knew.
The people who really cared--
there was a little bit of
word-of-mouth that went around.
There was the rating systems
online and things like that.
But when you ask around, there
was at least a half dozen
that were being used
and nobody quite
knew whether they
were good or not.
And basically, everybody had a
different standard with respect
to whether they would use them.
And so, recently,
they've changed.
They've started to endorse apps.
The MBTA this year endorsed
Transit as their app.
In a lot of cities, City
Mapper has been become
the standard for most people.
And so, there's
two or three that
are reasonably good both in the
design and in the information.
But I'll talk about the good
and the bad of these in a second
here So I've put three--
yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So regarding these
apps [INAUDIBLE] have you also
looked at different levels of
perspective of how people use
the information, especially how
features, about income levels--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There's been very little.
And there is some
research going on.
It's a real question.
The research question is, have
these changed people's habits?
Has it changed their behavior?
And there's not a
lot of evidence.
I don't know.
Gabrielle, do you
have any examples
that you'd like to throw out?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Candace Brakewood, who was
a graduate student here
and then went on to get
her PhD at Georgia Tech,
has done some good
research on this.
But it's limited, in
terms of the samples.
And it's not
conclusive with respect
to across the spectrum
of the use of the thing.
AUDIENCE: I ask because not
only because the process
being used [INAUDIBLE]
but because many
of these points that we
were just talking about
are being emulated in
the development world.
And I think it's the
way we should go.
But if access to this data--
if people are not using this
data in the developed world,
then I also believe
that policy is
geared towards encouraging
people or making this data
more accessible [INAUDIBLE]
people [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And I think-- my feeling
about this whole area
is it's got more questions
left than answers.
There's not a definitive
way, essentially.
So I think we should we should
talk about it as we go here.
We'll see.
So the basic aspects of these
things you probably know.
The best ones really depend
on knowing your location.
So again, you have to
give the app permission
to know your location
through your smartphone.
If you don't do that, they
don't work well at all.
Because, basically,
then you have
to tell them where you are.
And most of them don't even
have a good way to do that.
The NextBus one, which
was the earliest one,
does have a drop-down
menu, if you don't want
to tell them your location.
And you can just
pick as you go down.
But the other ones
don't really offer that.
You basically have to
tell them the location.
And it works well.
It knows where you
are right away.
It looks at
everything around you
and it gives you the schedules,
the next couple buses
that are right around you.
And so you can download
any of these things
and see how it works.
I go between
NextBus and Transit.
I haven't used
CityMapper that much.
Although in Europe,
almost everyone
uses CityMapper much more
than any of these other ones.
The newest thing has been
providing these other modes.
So essentially on Transit
now, you can order an Uber.
And you could look at anyone
who wants to give them
data, essentially, of options.
And so, I don't think
Bridge is on there.
But I've seen the car
sharing things on there, too.
So it becomes other
mobility services as well as
public transit.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I suspected that
when those Uber services
TNCs started popping
up on the transit apps,
I suspected that
they might be paying
those apps to have that option.
Because those options didn't
exist until not too long ago.
And suddenly, you
see this option.
Is there any truth to that?
PROFESSOR: Well, the
first one that tried
is a thing that's extinct now.
It's called RideScout.
RideScout was the first
one who tried to put
all these things together.
And they actually got resistance
at first from Uber and Lyft.
Because at the
beginning, Uber and Lyft
felt like they had all the
demand that they could handle.
And they wanted people
to go to their app.
They didn't want to pay them.
Now, I don't know.
This Transit app clearly has it.
And a lot of the other ones--
CityMapper also does.
Yeah.
So I think they are paying them.
But that's the maturity
of the TNCs as well.
Because they're trying to get as
much market share as they can.
And also because Uber
has so much money,
they just throw it at
everything in order
to get as much as they want.
Don't worry, I'll make other
editorial comments about Uber
as we go along.
[LAUGHING]
All right.
So this is the possibilities.
And the last is, can we attract
more customers using these?
And that's the open question.
There's some
indication that we can.
I think, from a
research side, we
want to do more testing of
pilot projects to see if we can.
I believe the second
point is really important.
We need not only information,
but integrated payment
mechanisms on the phone so
that you don't have a separate
barrier to taking
transit, which is,
you gotta get a fare card or you
gotta put money in the fare box
or you gotta--
there's some transaction
cost with the way
fares are in Transit.
If it's all on the phone
and it's all together,
it really makes it a
lot easier, I think.
And so, feel that if you put
the two together, you get more.
There aren't too many
people that have done that.
Chicago has the Ventra system
that does, to a large degree,
do this.
They're only doing it for
transit systems in Chicago.
They're doing it for the CTA.
But you can buy a
metro ticket now.
So it's actually multi
operator in the Chicago area.
It's the commuter rail.
And you can also
use it for PACE.
So it's an account
based system on an app.
And then you can get information
in terms of the services
as well.
So it's getting there.
There aren't too many systems.
Dallas uses information app
that includes payment as well--
unlimited.
There's a few of them out there.
London's got the payment.
And now they're doing the
app for the information.
So they were ahead in terms of
different payment mechanisms.
So it's getting there.
The question really
is, what do you need
to get people's eyes on it?
And right now, I believe
it's mostly word-of-mouth.
Those transit agencies spend
very, very little on marketing.
They used to do advertising
and things like that.
All that stuff's gone by
the board with the operating
resource constraints
they've had.
So it's like a lot of things.
There's all these
new things out there.
But how do you get people
to even look at it.
And that's a big question
that the big companies
know how to do.
The transit agencies clearly
haven't figured that out yet.
goes a little further.
So this is an idea
that when London
was talking about integrated
payment on a phone
and using your credit
card account to do it.
George Kocher said,
yeah, don't stop there.
Do all the information, as well.
And you can essentially just
have the whole transaction
with public transit and,
potentially, other mobility
services right in your pocket.
The public sector
has been wary of is
this whole idea of tracking
your movements and keeping it.
And that has been
a difficult thing
to get over even
in the research.
We've tried to do
little pilot projects.
And the amount of
bureaucracy you
have to go through in order to
essentially ask people if we
can track their movements--
which, by the way,
when you do ask them,
and you tell them what you're
doing it for, especially
for transit, over 50% is our
experience actually agree.
So it's a large sample of
the users agree to this.
Because, essentially,
they see the value
at some of the information
that's coming back.
So the challenges that are left.
There's still some
agencies, when
you go from city
to city, that don't
have a lot of good
real time information.
So the apps don't
work very well.
And for the life of me, it's
just a matter of inertia,
I believe, in these places.
Although in some
cases, they just
don't have the technology staff.
I mean, they're below
water all the time,
in terms of the projects
they have on technology.
And this is not their
highest priority.
But we still have a lot
of cities that aren't
releasing the real time data.
So some of these
apps just don't work.
The standard format
for the schedule data
is pretty much established--
the general transit data feed.
But the GTA [? available ?] time
is not that well established.
And most cities that provide
real time data to the public
do it this way.
But they sometimes do
it in a different way.
So actually, MBTA
has two formats.
And it turns out
that right now--
the GTA vest format,
and you can correct me
on this one, Gabrielle.
But the GTA vest format
requires the developers
to download all of the
data for all of the routes
when they ask for it.
It's setup for
somebody who wants
to pull every route,
whereas in some cases,
if you want to do this faster
and you want to do it smarter,
you don't want to keep
pulling the whole system.
Because you can't
do it fast enough.
And I think this is something
we found when we were actually
using it for a
different purpose--
for an internal purpose.
But we wanted to use their
separate API to their database
where this data resides.
Is that--
AUDIENCE: It's mostly correct.
One distinction [INAUDIBLE]
[? format ?] [INAUDIBLE] data
[INAUDIBLE] agencies like the
[? MBTA ?] [INAUDIBLE] one
example [INAUDIBLE] is the
waiting time for the Green
Line.
So they've developed a
custom API [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Based on that.
The biggest issue with
all of these apps,
really, is they don't
work well in predicting
when the bus is going
to arrive unless there's
no traffic out there.
So when there are generally good
conditions in terms of traffic,
they're generally good at
predicting the arrival.
When there's disruptions
and when there's
any significant
level of congestion,
they always underestimate the
time that you're going to wait.
And you can see this.
And people get very,
very frustrated
when it says it's going
to arrive in 4 minutes,
and it takes 8 or 9 minutes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you say something
about when the code shows
the vehicle [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, the Transit app does that.
You can push it and see the
map and see where the bus is.
And so, that helps.
Because when you get
to know your route
and you get to know how long
it generally takes when--
I take the route 1
bus towards Harvard.
So I look out over the bridge.
And if the bridge is backed
up and it says 3 minutes,
I know it's really
about 8 to 10 minutes.
So you're right.
It does help when it does that.
But frankly, for everyone,
that's another button.
You have to scroll through
the map to see if it's there.
The vehicles don't
always show up.
Because that vehicle hadn't
been pulled in the last--
whatever-- minutes or something.
And there's a lag time.
There's a lag time with
the update on this thing.
There's a student in
electrical engineering
who wants to do his master's
thesis on throwing out--
most of these
predictions in Boston
are based on the NextBus
black box algorithm.
And we don't know
exactly what's in there.
It's mostly based on historical
information about travel times
on the route.
So the way the algorithm
generally works
is historical travel times
on the route by time-of-day.
And then it puts in a little bit
of the last one or two buses.
But we don't think it
puts in enough of that.
So there is a student in
electrical engineering
who wants to perhaps
do a master's program.
Because he is very frustrated
at the MIT shuttle predictions,
which are always
not very accurate.
And he wants to throw out
the NextBus predictions
and put in the
homegrown prediction.
And so we'll see
how that works out.
AUDIENCE: I guess, the
next level for these apps
is to pull data from
Waze or some live data
I think it's the big
problem which is how much
longer it actually will take
the bus to get from A to B.
And then there's the
advantage, thinking of Waze,
of having that
they're linking a lot
more vehicles and people
are transmitting this,
well then integrate
expected Transit travel
times and the actual
travel time on the road.
We could integrate that.
And it would be a
very powerful tool.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's exactly what
he is going to do.
He's going to use the
Google real time traffic.
And then, so, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when
you the [INAUDIBLE] transit
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's using their--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think
on Google Transit,
there's a little indicator
whether it's real time or not
real time.
And if that's bolded,
you know it's real time.
And it's based on something.
But again, those companies--
it's just like NextBus.
They have their own algorithm.
And the question really is--
I don't know who the
people in the traffic field
are, whether they're looking
at these predictions.
But I know if you look
at the Bluetooth signs
on the traffic side,
there's a huge lag effect.
So when traffic is building
up, you never get enough--
the Bluetooth
prediction is too low.
When traffic is coming down,
the Bluetooth projection
is too high.
And I look at this all
the time on the highways.
Because I gotta go back
and forth to Cape Cod.
And it's amazing to see, it
is better than the Transit
predictions, I
can tell you that.
The other issue with
the Transit predictions
is they've got issues that
the Traffic doesn't have.
They got dwell
time at the stops.
And all it takes is one
wheelchair at Central Square
to be loaded and that thing
is off by 2 or 3 minutes, just
like that.
Because it takes 2 or 3
minutes to load a wheelchair
and secure the wheelchair.
And then there's sometimes a
crowd coming out of the subway.
And depending on the
driver, they wave
on the people who they
think have passes.
Other drivers, they tell
him to get on the back door.
There's other drivers
say, no, you gotta--
and then other drivers insist
you get behind the yellow line.
And they'll sit there
at the stop for awhile.
So there's all this
driver behavior,
not to speak of the difference
in pulling in and out of stops
among drivers, which you don't
have in the general traffic
flow.
So you got the
general traffic, you
got the dwell times for
things like handicap vehicles.
So it's a huge problem.
It's not it's not a
simple algorithm to solve.
It's one of those things that we
should be looking to do better.
In major disruptions,
it really becomes
an issue of how much
do you tell the public,
let's do something else.
This bus is not coming in any
reasonable amount of time.
You can walk there a lot faster.
And all the transit
agencies have been
reluctant to figure that out.
Although London is a lot
closer to thinking about,
how do we tell people
about disruptions?
And how much do we divert
them from their normal path?
But there's not a lot
of real good research
out there about how to do that.
There is an issue with
the transit agencies
that, again, it's because
it's a government agency.
And this is probably more in
the US than anywhere else.
But because of the Americans
with Disabilities Act,
certain types of
information can't
be given out to the public
by the transit agency
unless it's fully accessible.
And so, one of the reasons
we don't have more bus
stop signs is because small bus
stop signs on small monitors
are not accessible under
the terms of the Americans
with Disabilities Act.
So they have to spend a lot more
money doing accessible signs.
And I would argue that
this is something that's--
you can buy every disabled user
an accessible smartphone app
built for that
cheaper than making
every piece of
information accessible.
But there's been no
movement on this.
That's just an accepted fact.
What they've done to get
around this a little bit is
they say to the cities and
towns or somebody else--
the federal transit agency
has their interpretation
of an accessible
sign, and other people
have different interpretations.
So there is some
movement allowing.
Like these private
transit screens
you see, they have to be paid
for with non-federal money,
essentially.
And they're paid for,
usually, by private people
or by the city under
some non-federal grant.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do they have
to work with the NextBus
commission [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Have to
have an audible thing
or a Braille thing or
something like that.
Yeah.
And finally, this idea
of private ride sharing.
And so, we have
all these systems
and private operators that
are being incorporated here.
But why not-- you can find me.
If I want to give you a ride
from MIT to west Cambridge,
why can't I get in that app?
And then you could pay me
a few bucks for that ride.
And there's a few people who
are developing mostly web
applications right
now, but are starting
to develop the phone
apps to do private ride
sharing in this, as well.
The Ubers of the world don't
like these things at all.
And I don't really have any
good examples of people doing it
on a wide-scale basis.
But MIT is very
interested in doing this
within their mobile app.
So--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If I can give you an example.
In Israel, where I come
from, Uber and Lyft
have not been allowed in Israel.
But they have allowed Google.
And Google started privately
developing consultant areas
where people use exactly
these services where
if a private
individual says, I'm
going from a suburb to the beach
right now at this time of day.
If you want to join me and pay
me a few bucks for the ride.
So Google actually has
started a pilot [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I would argue
that this might not
be the best thing for Transit
if we got everybody sharing
rides all the time.
But for the metropolitan
area and urban area,
it's probably a great thing.
And it's better than having
Uber and Lyft drivers
who, when they're not
full, running around empty.
Because they're basically
a purposeful trip
that's being made, as opposed
to just being a business.
So these are potential
research questions.
I think I've talked about
the arrival predictions.
The second one is important.
We do a lot of research
in the Transit lab
about this using the
real time information,
both from their vehicles
and from customers.
Much less, thus far, from
customers in a real time
framework.
But if we have that kind
of information coming
in all the time, how do
they make adjustments
to the operating plan?
So for example, the simplest one
of these is on ball game days.
They store trains
outside of Kenmore Square
and outside of
the Boston Garden.
And then they only release
them when the crowd shows up
on the platform.
But it's still very low tech.
There's a guy down there.
And he says, send one in.
[LAUGHING]
But if you think about
that on a smaller scale,
if a school gets out, and it's
on the Riverside line on the D
branch, instead of on
the even headway at 3:48,
you dispatch it a
little bit early.
Because you knew the
school just got out.
And you will pick up that
school load right away.
And then the next
bus can pick up
all the rest of the passengers.
Or maybe they'll put two in
a row or something like that.
This is good research.
It's still in its infancy, I
would suggest, at this point.
The travel behavior
question is paramount.
And as I said, I don't know of
really good research on this.
And the bad part about it
is I think any research that
relies on surveys, revealed
behavior, or stated behavior
is just no good anymore.
It may have been
good in the past
or they may have been lying
to us about how good it was.
But right now, we need something
that looks at the real data.
And so, this is where
the tracking data is key.
And it's starting to be done.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I worked
in industry data before this.
Most of the issues we
had in the private sector
were overcome by making
the data fully anonymous.
Is that still not the case
with these Transit systems?
Couldn't you just have instead
of me being Scott Foster,
I'd be number 12379.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It is clearly doable.
And it is done.
We hashed the names
and the serial numbers
and all that stuff.
But-- I just had a conversation
about this with a public agency
person this morning--
they get very concerned
about small numbers.
And on Transit, there's
a lot of small numbers.
If you're actually looking
at OD movements from A
to B in the early morning,
there may be only a couple
of people doing that.
And so then they get
nervous about doing that.
And I would argue that
those are the very things
we want to learn about.
Because you look at the bus.
And you know it's full
at 8:00 in the morning.
But where should that bus be,
maybe, at 6:00 in the morning?
It maybe should be
somewhere very different.
And we have to use this
automated data to do that.
And we'd like to track
who who's using it
and how they're using it.
Because they might be using
it very, very differently.
I don't know if you've noticed
this advocacy group, Transit
Matters in the Boston area,
but they have this proposal
for all night service.
And it's different than
the late night service
proposal in that it's looking
at service for workers early
in the morning and at
the airport and things
like-- this guy knows it.
Yeah.
He did.
OK.
But anyway, it's just,
that makes sense.
But what you don't
have is good data
about who's using it where.
And there's not enough out
there to really measure it,
in that particular case.
Because there would
be induced demand.
AUDIENCE: So we can guess at
where people are going just
by where [INAUDIBLE] can't get
the regularity when you get
the small [INAUDIBLE]
And the private sector
is the same thing.
You have to make
sure you don't come
close to identifying
an individual--
customer level data.
So it's always
aggregated in some way
to make sure that you
couldn't figure it out.
You have all the
people maybe getting
on [INAUDIBLE] between
5:00 AM and 6:00 AM knowing
that they got on at 5:05.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And there's a whole spectrum
here of what is acceptable
and what is not.
I guess, I just
argue, and I've said--
I had a TRB talk
about five years ago
about how the phone knows
when I'm near a pizza spot.
And it sends me an ad.
And I said, you know,
and if you actually
look at the terms of use
of Google on those phones,
it's like they can do
anything with that.
They can look at
your phone call.
If you actually
read those things,
they use every piece of data
that they have accessible
almost any way they want.
And if you say you
decline, then you're
location stuff
doesn't work ever.
So it's a mess.
And if these folks
can get you to do it,
I say, well, the private
sector is doing it.
There isn't many bad things
in the public sector.
People think, oh, they'll
arrest you or something.
And maybe, in this case,
maybe these days they will.
I don't know.
[LAUGHING] But in the old days,
when I was talking about this,
I said, you know, come on.
Let the government do its job in
the sense of planning services.
Yeah.
So one thing that
comes out of this,
and this is customer information
and marketing combined,
if we have a lot of this
automated fare data,
on a voluntary basis, we
can create customer panels.
So you can ask people, we'd
like to help plan things better.
Let's put these panels together.
We're going to use your
data for two months.
And we want to ask you some
questions about your attitudes
and things.
And this is done a lot
in the private sector.
When we've done it, a lot--
anywhere between 35%
and 50% have said, yes.
You can essentially do
this on an ongoing basis.
And you can create
a very large panel.
And you can randomly select
them for other little surveys.
And then you could see if
they react with respect
to their particular
travel behavior.
And so, I think this
is the way we learn
the travel behavior impacts.
But you gotta get a big panel.
And so far, the
transit agencies have
been a little
worried about this,
again, from the
privacy perspective.
I say, if people agree,
there's no privacy issue.
And then you can
continually enrich this.
You could keep recruiting
people for this
so that there is a lot of churn
in the transit ridership--
that people don't stay
forever riding the bus.
Because they move or they get
a new job or they buy a car.
The thing you could then
move to is pilot programs.
And you could select
people on these panels
to be offered new things.
And so this thing
that we're trying
to get started with the CTA is
to do mobility as a service.
So they have this Ventra app.
It works really, really
well for transit.
Well, why not put bike sharing,
car sharing, potentially TNCs
on this app?
And do it in a way
that the transit agency
dictates who gets paid and
how much they get paid.
And this is a big sell.
Because they see Ubers and
Lyfts and the car-sharing people
as the evil empire.
But what we say is, do
it on a pilot basis,
because you can get
these individual panels.
You could do it on a
general public basis,
if they volunteer.
Or you could do it
through employers,
which, then, is
another way transit,
I think, has underutilized their
market strength, in a sense.
Employers, in large
cities, have a motivation
to promote transit.
Because if they don't
promote transit,
they have to make sure that
their employees can find
parking near their offices.
So they either have
to provide the parking
or they have to provide
a parking subsidy.
As many of you know, we
have been doing a lot here
in MIT with this and trying
to change the behavior
by essentially giving a free
transit pass to every employer
and charging daily for
parking as opposed to what
used to be a Either, Or.
You pick transit or
you pick parking.
You can do all these
things to learn.
But what it all depends
on is this mobile data
and other automated data
sources to tie it all together.
I think one of the issues
that this will also help
is you can get
feedback from people
about what they want to know
when they want to know it.
So you can't do that in a
fully-automated fashion.
So these panels are
the only way that you
can get to a large
representative group of people
and quiz them about when
they had bad service
and what they did and
what kind of information
that you need to get to them.
So the next four slides
are from Montreal.
And Isabelle Trottier presented
them a couple of years
ago when she came down here
to what we call the Transit
Leaders Roundtable.
And they are a little
bit ahead of the curve
in terms of providing
mobility as a service.
And I'll just give
you some examples.
This is mostly
oriented towards biking
in Montreal and bike sharing.
But I picked it,
because I have an ax
to grind about the biking.
And so, I'm not
quite as bad as Fred.
But I have a good example here.
So the bicycles are
growing in popularity.
I don't know exactly what
passport mobility is.
I don't remember what it is.
But it's essentially
a way to buy things.
I think it's an account
that you can use.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So the reason I picked
the bicycle here is this
is a place that has been very
successful at combining bikes
and buses in the same
lane, which we're
having a huge fight here
in the Boston area about,
whether it's safe or not.
And they have done and recently
have been doing studies of this
and looking at where it works
and where it doesn't work.
And they've brought the bicycle
people in to see the data
and do it transparently.
And I argue, we have
to do this in Boston
or else the MBTA is dead.
There's a bunch of examples.
The conclusion drawn from
the first pilot project
was it's both possible
and even desirable.
It's safe, and it's functional.
The cyclists like it.
The bus performance-- they used
to have the lane by themselves.
Now they don't.
It's not gone down.
And they're deploying it
now, on a case by case basis,
depending a little
bit on the layout
of the streets and the lanes.
And so my little commercial is
we need to do this for mobility
in the Boston area.
So my final slide
in this whole area
is Lead to a Re-definition
of Public Transit.
And I think that we're
almost there, at this point.
All these mobility
services are being--
the same people are using all
of these mobility services.
There are now the
private car users.
And there are people
using mobility services.
And they're using a
combination of them.
I did talk two
years ago when they
did the first study of users in
the New York City area of Uber
and taxis and public transit.
And at the time, the
Uber fare in Manhattan
averaged about $20, which
was still pretty high.
And the analysis said that
if it got down to around $10,
on average, and people used
1/3 third of their trips--
all their trip making on Uber--
and 2/3 on transit,
you would actually
spend less on that combination
than buying a car even
in the outer
Boroughs of New York.
So what's happened
in the meantime
is that Uber fares
have come down.
And they're probably at that
level, as an average, now.
So that means if you're
economically savvy,
you're crazy to be
operating a car.
Because, generally,
for the longer trips
you can take the subway.
And for the shorter
trips you take Uber.
And the question is,
has it changed behavior?
The New York City people say,
there's more cars in Manhattan.
So that indicates there
are more people using Uber.
Because they're not using more
private cars in Manhattan.
Because they have
no place to park.
So this is a thing
that transit is
extremely worried about
but it's doing very little.
And the question is, can
we control this in any way?
And I would argue,
the only way they
can do it is by having
a joint deal where
they give information and
payment together on an app.
And they give you
unlimited rides on transit.
a certain number
of rides on these other modes.
And basically, it's a good
economic deal for everyone.
And you market it like that.
Because frankly, transit
has been cutting back
the really bad
off-peak services.
Because they can't afford to
subsidize it at $10 a ride.
And if they only subsidize--
for example, you might give them
a certain number of Uber trips
that are just to and
from rail stations.
Because they can do
this geofencing thing.
Or you might give a
subsidy for Uber trips
up to a certain amount per trip
for a certain number of trips.
There's a whole bunch of
bundling that you can do here.
And what I'm saying
is that we gotta
do this in a series of
controlled experiments
and learn what people want
and what people use and learn,
frankly, whether we're going
to end up being just high
frequency corridor routes left.
And there is a real
debate about this.
And there's a real
debate about whether this
is where we're going to end up
or whether Uber and Lyft are
going to go out of business.
Because they, right now,
have unsustainable fares.
That's what the transit
people hope and bet on.
But I'm not sure that's
going to happen or not.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's what's
really interesting to me.
I definitely agree these
are going to have phenomenal
impact..
But in London, they are
investing huge amounts
of money for Crossrail
and Crossrail 2, which
are high frequency routes.
But in cities where
the road layout is not
a grid they have to
scale larger, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And London's doing it largely
on the economic theory
of agglomeration--
that they have such a density
of employment opportunities
and other activities
that are altogether,
they should have an economic
benefit to the thing.
Frankly, every
developed country,
every almost developing
country in the world
is doing more investment in
transit than the United States.
And Fred would argue
that we should just
forget about all this stuff
and just build more rail
lines in certain places.
I think that, in
many cities, we're
beyond a little bit of that.
Because the sprawl is so great.
It's right.
In the big old cities,
the densities--
if we want to increase the
density in Boston or in New
York or Philadelphia, yes,
you have to have rail.
Because essentially, you can't
increase the density anymore.
Because there's no
place to put the cars.
But in some of these other
cities that are spread out
more, it's just not as
clear of what you should
do in terms of investment.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
You said that
transit authorities
are worried about this.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Nationally,
for the last decade,
transit ridership
has gone up steadily.
And everybody was really happy.
The last two to three
years, bus ridership-- not
rail ridership-- bus
ridership has gone down.
And all the large cities.
And everybody's debating about
what's the cause of that.
Is it just the gas prices?
Is it Uber and Lyft?
What is it?
And they're worried.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Nationally?
Yeah.
There's a big debate about
why did D.C. has gone down.
Because they've had
all these disruption
because of the
safety and because
of the reconstruction of things.
So D.C. is a special case.
But New York flattened out.
That's right.
And New York was going up.
And nobody can argue it's the
economy, because the economy
has been growing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Go ahead.
[LAUGHING] He knows
this better than I do.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: They're
skeptical in Montreal?
AUDIENCE: Can't decide it.
There is skepticism in Montreal.
In theory it should work.
Because buses and some high
schools average the same speed.
In practice, the cyclist
goes 15 miles an hour.
The bus goes
zero/thirty zero/thirty
So there might be a
leapfrog leaping out anyway.
I think what the
issue is that cyclists
feel that they might get
squeezed [? there. ?]
There's two issues.
One is that if you just have--
I think for really short
segments, these makes sense.
For [INAUDIBLE] you're probably
thinking of [INAUDIBLE]..
A couple hundred yards
with a huge bottleneck.
And frankly, if a bus
had to follow a cyclist
at 8 miles an hour, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It wouldn't matter.
AUDIENCE: It would still be
much faster than a car going
two or three lights.
But in longer corridors,
especially where
you have the bus pulling
from the curve and back,
it becomes more of an issue.
There's the question of
whether you could build
some kind of floating bus stop.
So you'd have separation
at the bus stops.
And the vehicles would
never have to cross paths.
And the buses could
pass the cyclists.
And the cyclists could pass
the buses where needed.
But that's more, I think, cities
sort of see this as a panacea
where they can lay down
some [INAUDIBLE] for that.
And it's not a
problem [INAUDIBLE]
mention that in
[INAUDIBLE] in Madison
they have shared bus bike lanes.
And they work pretty well.
And I don't disagree.
But those are also some
five lane wide streets
where they can provide
a really wide facility.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It does depend on the
width of the lane.
I agree [INAUDIBLE] agree that
we could do a lot with queue
jump lanes--
not fully dedicated lanes.
We can't give up a full lane all
the way up and down Mass Ave.
But in front of MIT, we can.
From the river to
Albany Street, we can.
Because there's no
commercial activity.
We have 17 parking spaces out
here in front of 77 Mass Ave.
17 spaces.
You can put them on
Amherst Alley really easily
and have all this
space that we could
devote for bikes and buses.
So what I would argue is,
we need queue jump lanes.
A lot of people talk about--
did Peter Firth
talk about TSP yet?
OK.
He's coming.
Peter's going to come and talk
about Transit Signal Priority.
And listen carefully.
Because transit signal priority
provides very, very small
improvements, especially if
the bus is stuck behind a car.
And so, the question is,
transit signal priority
works well when at the
congested intersections
we have a queue jump lane
that the bus can get around
the long line of cars that
might be there in the rush hour.
And so we need both.
And what I would argue is
that in those small segments,
the buses can share
it with bikes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Enforcement.
Yeah.
I mean that's the only--
AUDIENCE: In San
Francisco [INAUDIBLE]
driver literally
busted out camera
in front of driver [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: They can push.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Take
pictures [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think a lot of people do that.
Yeah.
I think London does
the same thing.
London has a lot of these.
And they--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Bus lanes and there
are also taxi lanes [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And they're
also bike lanes.
And in London, it
looks scary to me.
Because they go so fast.
But around here,
as Ari says, you
know if we get seven or eight
miles an hour out of a bus,
we're happy.
Because they're only
average four or five.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: That seven
or eight miles an hour
is enough to get to a
light that's actually
held green for ten seconds so if
that light changes [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: I don't see
why that problem is
unique to the facility.
Because even if the bus is
sharing a lane of traffic
and the bike lane
is not a bike lane,
there's still
[INAUDIBLE] conflict.
AUDIENCE: That's certainly true.
I think what the issue
is that cyclists--
some cyclists can
be very special.
And I'm not talking about
anyone who works at the City
of Cambridge..
There are some cycling
advocates who would rather--
there are some cyclists
and cycling advocates
who don't understand that
there were transit issues
before traffic [INAUDIBLE].
And there needs to be a bit of
a detente between the cyclists
and the transit users.
The problem-- I think
Frank pointed this out--
is that the cyclists are
meant for [INAUDIBLE] more
organizers than cyclists who are
put in mortal danger every time
they're going somewhere.
And transit users are
just like [INAUDIBLE]..
And there's a difference
between those two groups.
And I know that this
past November, I
think in the past fall I'm on
the Cambridge Cycling Committee
and I try to be
a voice of reason
for transit as well on
those bicycle committees.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The only
voice of reason.
No.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sometimes there
can be [INAUDIBLE]
bus stops on Mass Ave.
PROFESSOR: Because 40% of the
people on Mass Ave in the rush
hour are on buses.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And 50% of
them are on bikes.
PROFESSOR: It's even more.
Yeah.
It's almost 50%.
And a lot of the
arterials around here,
that's the percentage.
It's between 35% and 50%
of the people are on buses.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] The bike
doesn't take up that much room.
So the issue, I think,
winds up being that--
PROFESSOR: We're off topic here.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: We had a
nice conversation.
I think when you get people
in the same room they
start to understand that
there's a give and take.
[INAUDIBLE] and
I said, if you're
doing planning an
isolation where you talk
to bike people and they, say, we
want X and you talk to transit
people and they say they
want Y, the easiest thing
is to do nothing.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think the bus
lane actually gets--
although, these
days I'm not sure--
but I would say that the bus
lanes get more adverse reaction
from the drivers than
the bike lanes do.
Because they don't seem to
take away driving lanes.
Whereas a bus lane
seems to either take
a driving or a
parking lane away.
And so, it gets more
opposition from the drivers.
But there's a quote.
I forget the quote now.
But basically,
urbanologists-- people--
have started to
realize that we're
spending tons and tons of
money doing bike facilities
in these urban areas.
And we're spending nothing
on transit facilities.
And that's a long-term disaster.
Because essentially,
there is a limit
on the amount of bike use, I
think, in any of these places.
Because there's lots of people.
I used to bike.
I live four miles away.
I'm getting old.
So I'm losing a little bit of my
perception and stuff like that.
I had a couple of close calls.
I stopped.
I basically just stopped.
I said, I'll bike
when I go to Cape Cod.
I'm not going to bike
in these streets.
Mainly I was afraid
of the other bikers
then I was as opposed to
being afraid of the cars.
And there's lots of
people that just can't.
And a lot of those people
want to take buses.
But they also don't want to be
held up in congestion streets
all the time.
So can we switch?
I don't know your computer.
Can we switch to the other one?
We'll just get started on
the Performance Measurement.
And then we'll go
into the next one.
Great.
The reading, I
think, is important.
It's a dry topic.
It's how transit authorities
evaluate themselves
and how they evaluate themselves
with respect to other transit
authorities.
But it's important.
Because if they don't do
performance measurement,
nobody improves.
And there's example
after example.
The two best examples,
from my perspective,
are the CTA, about
five years ago,
instituted this rigorous
performance measurements regime
that the general manager
sat at a weekly meeting
on a rotating basis
with every department
and developed
performance measures
and tracked them
for each department.
And the performance, almost
universally, went up.
There's a set of slides
that I can't go over.
But we'll put on
Stellar about this.
It's an amazing story, I think.
The GM was only
there for two years.
He was one of these
management by data types.
And then he got moved to
run the school department,
for God's sake.
I don't know why.
But, anyway.
And the other example
really is the MBTA
under the fiscal management
control board, where they've
insisted that there
be regular updates
and data-driven analyses.
And if you look at the progress
on things like Overtime,
and essentially, things that
are inefficient, generally,
they've improved.
And there's a lot more to
improve here at the MBTA.
And there's a lot
of issues that can't
be solved just by better
management and performance
measurement.
But there's a lot that can.
And so, I think this is
a really important topic.
So what we have
here is a little bit
of justification of doing this.
There is an older report
that's really good--
TCRP 88 that essentially
is a cookbook
on how to develop a
performance management
system for your transit agency.
And it's a really good report
with respect to the measures
you use.
And they divide into small,
medium, and large urban areas.
And they give different measures
for four different ones.
A lot of people want to compare
themselves to other people.
There's this national database.
And this is the website.
And you can see
performance measures
from everyone in the
country on a pretty much
equitable reasonable basis.
And then there's the concept
of performance audits, which
we'll talk a little bit about.
So why do it?
Basically, whatever
gets measured
gets noticed by management.
And everybody's into these
new management dashboards
with key performance indicators.
It can be done and
not have an impact.
But I feel like,
whatever that indicator
is, people manage to it.
Sometimes the indicator
is the wrong indicator.
And it's not so good.
Because it's the easy one to
measure as opposed to what
they should be focused on.
Many of them are--
the measures that the board
and the top management look at
are oriented to the
supply of the transit--
what the vehicles did
as opposed to what
the passenger experienced.
The best example
of that is when you
look at on-time performance.
They measure it
within 2 or 3 minutes.
And that doesn't mean anything
if the bus is supposed
to come every 7 or 8 minutes.
Because basically, there's
this phenomenon of long gaps
and then followed by bunches.
There's very few passengers
on the bunch buses, especially
the second and third one.
And most of the people
are on the crowded bus
who had to wait, which
is the first one.
And they had to wait
much longer for that.
So the wait time for
passengers is not
linearly related to this
on-time performance measure
that they have.
So you actually should be
trying to measure effective wait
time for all passengers.
And that should be
your measure for most
of the transit services.
They also use some of
the performance measures
on a system basis for
funding allocation.
I'll mention a few things there.
I talked about this TCRP Report.
It's nice.
And I think it used to have
a website associated with it.
So you could
actually go in there
and put your own
program together.
I'm not sure if it still does.
Because it's fairly old.
But it's nice in that it
isn't one prescribed thing.
It gives you a lot
of different options.
And you can tailor it
to your urban area.
This is the process that
they recommend in the report.
Again, this is an internal
performance measurement
system--
performance management system.
And it's a top-down to find
your goals and objectives get
management support.
And I guess, the second
one is extremely important.
I used to, as my olden
days as a consultant,
I used to do transit performance
audits for transit agencies.
And the experiences
varied further
than anyone could imagine.
I'd been in some
transit authorities.
The first meeting was
with the general manager.
And he says, go get 'em.
And he says, and come back
with all the information,
because I want to know it.
And you would do it.
And we'd come back
with the indicators.
And he'd say, OK, what
do I do about this?
What I do about this?
He'd bring the
departments in and says,
I'm not blaming anybody.
We just gotta
develop action plans
to get these things better.
And I've been in
other properties
where the general
manager said, literally,
on the first
meeting, you're here
because the state
makes me do this.
So I want you to get in and out
of here as quick as you can.
And basically, I know
how to manage my place.
You don't have to
tell me anything.
And now, all of these were
relatively small properties.
We did some larger properties.
But basically, there's
a tremendous variation
among management styles on this.
And so, if you're
going to do this,
you want top management to be
supportive right from the start
and to participate
in developing it.
The rest of it is intuitive.
The most important
thing is, how do
the results, when you
update all these measures,
get integrated into
how you actually
carry out the business?
And that is a hard
part sometimes.
And it's a part that
you need to think about.
And you gotta think about, what
can I do about this indicator?
And I think part of
when you're deciding
what the indicators are,
that's a big part is thinking
about that step 7 and 8.
And essentially, if
something's working
and you're making
progress, you keep it in.
If you don't, an 8, you throw
it out and try something else.
This is the way they've got
lists and lists of measures.
They've got bunches of tables.
And again, they have them
for large properties.
It makes sense for large
properties, medium, small,
actually under 50,000 people
in the metropolitan area.
So they basically
say, this is kind
of what we think
your capabilities are
based on staffing and
these kind of properties.
There's some more.
I'm not going to
go through these.
The NDT data.
How many people have
actually gone in
and looked at these tables?
Anybody?
Two.
OK.
You should all do this.
It's pretty interesting.
They've got a whole range
of transit properties
across the country.
And you can sort
them in various ways.
You can download reports.
You can download
it in CSV files.
You can see how your city
stacks up against other cities.
Consultants use
these all the time.
And the good thing about
it is at the beginning when
they first developed
this, definitions
were variable across cities.
And each year, the
government has done
what big bureaucracies do well.
They started to
standardize this.
And they call you up if
they don't like your number.
And they also call you
up if your numbers change
from year to year too much.
And they ask you why.
And so there's an
auditing process
of the data that's in here.
Now the only
downside of it is it
got big quick when they first
developed it in the 80s.
And then there was a backlash
from the transit agencies
in the city saying,
you're asking us
for too much information.
This costs too much.
And so, I don't think they've
added the proper updating of it
with respect to developments
that have been in the transit
over the last 10
or 15 years or so.
And there still is
some inconsistency.
There's still a
little bit of latitude
on how you allocate your costs.
That's the hardest thing.
And have you guys had
cost allocation models?
Yeah.
So you saw the uncertainty
of exactly what you put--
all these costs-- what
category you put them in.
And so, that part, while
they define a lot of it,
they don't define it
down to the bottom.
And so, I think that there
is, especially in the costs.
So the cost effectiveness
numbers that come out of
here aren't necessarily
directly comparable
depending on the property and
how seriously they take it.
The other issue
with this is this
is another thing where
the management style--
some management actually
ask their people
to look at other properties
here and report back.
And they care about it.
And other management says,
just get that report done.
Get it out of here.
So this is a similar thing.
Leadership is important.
So this issue of
performance audits.
So outside of doing it with key
performance indicators going
to the board, there's
also these efforts
to do it comprehensively,
maybe a deeper dive, than you
would do on a regular basis.
And they usually bring in
outside people consultants
or maybe a state
group that comes in.
And they go around,
especially, like, say,
for the RTAs here in
Massachusetts that are all much
smaller than the MBTA--
they have a standardized
performance audit
group that goes around.
And they give them information.
I think the big issue,
especially in the smaller
properties, is they don't
have the resources to find out
what other people are doing
very easily as compared
to the larger cities who
just call up people and say,
I'm going to come down.
I want to hear about this.
Or they set up a
special panel and they
bring in some experts
on a particular issue.
What this process allows is
identifying critical issues
that are performance issues and
then allowing the consultant
to focus just on
those two or three
issues or the outside group
and say, give us information
about how we can improve
just in these areas.
And then it brings information
from other properties.
Because these people have
been doing it in other places.
And the big debate when
this first all started
and among the people who did
it was, should you focus on
internally in the trends in your
internal operation or should
you focus on how you
compare to other people?
And there's no the answer here.
I always said, it doesn't
hurt to look at outside.
But clearly, if you're
looking internally first,
you can see whether you're
getting better or worse.
And you know the
data is consistent.
And you know the issues that
you're having trouble with.
Because intuitively, you know
it as well as from the data.
So I would say, generally,
the peer comparisons were
often used by the outside
groups to say, where should we
focus going in?
And let's dig deeper
in these areas,
because these numbers look
a little bit out of context.
Almost done here.
So I'm going to press on for--
to--
So the bulk of the
effort was internally.
One thing that this
allows is because you
have this facilitator
and the outside group,
it allows you to tell
them, like a counselor,
this is why I really
can't get my job done.
And we really developed
a mode with these folks.
You can tell us.
We're not going to
attribute it to you.
We're not going to necessarily
go to your direct boss
about your complaint
to the direct boss.
But we might mention
this to somebody
higher up in a more general way.
And we had ways
of assuring them.
And so, employees
liked this, especially
if they were hitting roadblocks
in doing a better job.
And in small properties,
sometimes personalities
got in the way.
And so we would provide that
feedback to the top management
as long as they wanted it.
And just I'm aware of a
very significant state
program in California.
They have to do this
every three years.
It started at two.
Now it's down to three.
And they have a set format.
And they send the same kind
of people around to each one.
And there's some compliance
with state requirements
and funding and
things like that.
But it really was
a comprehensive.
And they looked in
these five focus areas.
And they essentially--
when you got the feedback
from most of the smaller
properties, at least,
they felt like this
was a great program.
Because it gave them the
ability to focus harder
on things on a periodic basis.
And then when you came back, you
measured those areas and said,
OK, what else was
going on at that point?
I think that's where
I'm going to stop.
Yeah.
Anybody have any last questions?
We can pick this up a little
bit in the service contracting
stuff.
Because it comes up there, too.
The difference
between performance
in your internal operations and
performance by your contractors
is nothing.
In fact, it's harder to
manage the service contract.
And we can talk about
that at the next one.
OK.
Anybody?
Great.
Thanks.